what's up guys everyone keeps asking me
what's going on with the dead limit
crisis and what do I think is going to
happen well this is a fluid situation
lots of things are changing but here's
my best take on all of it first of all
the United States of America is not
likely to default on their debt that is
an insane idea at the moment maybe
that'll change over the next couple of
days but as of right now it is very hard
to see a world where the us is going to
default on their debt but don't get so
excited there's going to be Madness in
the media the mainstream media is going
to hype this up they're gonna tell you
how the world is ending they're going to
brag about all the chaos how bad
political leaders on the right and the
left are how the president is willing to
work with people how the president is
not willing to work with people you're
going to hear it all every single
storyline possible is all engineered to
get you to click on those articles be
careful separate all of the noise from
the actual signal which is that the
United States is very unlikely to
default on their debt there's a whole
bunch of reasons why but how exactly is
the deal going to get done I think that
politicians are going to use this
opportunity to continue to campaign
that's right every time you see a
politician arguing in the media they're
campaigning they want you to know they
went to Washington and they're fighting
for you they're sitting there trying to
figure out exactly what they can say and
what they can do to get attention
because in politics getting attention is
a huge part of the game if you get
attention you get dollars if you get
attention in dollars you usually get
reelected that's the game of politics
and so I think that we'll continue to
see politicians play games the media
will hype it all up and enjoy all the
clicks but a deal will get done in the
11th hour now it does look likely that
the Democrats will have to Cave a little
bit to the Republicans and so the
Republicans will run around and they'll
say look look how smart we are we got
them to Cave the Democrats will step in
and they'll say look how morally just we
are we saved the United States from
defaulting by going ahead and agreeing
to this deal whether that happens or not
a deal is going to get done now that
doesn't also mean that just as soon as
the deal gets done the story is over in
fact I think that the United States
National Debt will hit an all-time high
by the summer time literally just within
a few weeks and then on top of that we
will have another debt limit crisis
within the next 36 months so just as in
the past this is simply a temporary
moment it's all bark and no bite we're
not going to have a default and we're
going to be right back in this situation
within three years that's because we
have a spending problem in the United
States and the national debt only knows
how to go up it never comes down but
then when you start to look at all the
problems they're going to be caused by
this and you add in that interest rates
will come down over the next 24 to 36
months and also we're going to see a
return to quantitative easing asset
prices are going to grind higher
throughout this as well as we take on
more debt as more money enters into this
system and there's this Tailwind from
monetary policy asset prices are going
to do well as you know regardless of the
asset class if you hold for long enough
over decades most assets appreciate
against the US dollar because the dollar
has to be devalued in order to pay off
the national debt or try to monetize it
now that leads me to where are people
going to go as we have seen throughout
the first five months of the year we
have seen many investors who are seeking
some sort of alternative they're looking
for insurance they want to know if the
United States actually defaults how bad
could the damage be and is my money safe
or not are my investments in my
portfolio actually going to do well or
do bad in that scenario so naturally
they're looking for an alternative
historically gold has served as a great
alternative it's outside the system and
if the United States was the default
gold probably would do pretty well but
now we have digital gold Bitcoin and
that seems to be the biggest beneficiary
of all all this chaos Bitcoin is up more
than 60 percent to start the year it was
the best performing asset in q1 of 2023
and there are many investors around the
world who are saying if I need a safe
haven if I need some sort of safety from
a default in the United States Bitcoin
might not be a bad option it's a
decentralized digital Network that's
backed by the strongest computer network
in the world it's outside the system
it's not controlled by anyone and
ultimately it serves as insurance
against all sorts of economic chaos now
Bitcoin may not be something that you
want to put 100 of your portfolio in I
don't suggest that but it does feel like
if you're going to have some sort of
economic hedge that merely putting a
small percentage of your portfolio in
that asset if the economic catastrophe
happens it will likely do pretty well
and so if you look at the politicians
they're yelling and screaming they're
all campaigning right now the media is
hyping them up they're putting that
battery in their back they're trying to
get them all beefed up so that they keep
it up so that the media companies keep
getting clicks don't get distracted by
the nonsense don't buy any of the
nonsense either no distractions and no
buying into the narratives at the end of
the day the United States really really
really really is incentivized not to
default and I think that's exactly
what's going to happen now the last
thing I'll say is I'm not changing
anything in my portfolio I'm not
changing any of my investment strategy
based on any of these assumptions this
is all predictions I don't have a
crystal ball I don't know what's going
to happen in the future and neither do
you and so naturally I'm doing what most
investors are going to do in this
situation I'm gonna keep doing what I
already was doing I don't see any major
change here and yes there's a risk of a
default but even in a default given how
much I've allocated to bitcoin naturally
I think that it'll do pretty well in
that scenario and so no changes for me
but I'd love to hear what you are doing
whether you're doing the same thing or
you're doing something differently leave
me a comment I'll try to respond as many
of them as I can that's it let's see
what happens we got a couple days the
treasury balance is falling the default
is approaching the media is yelling and
screaming the politicians are
campaigning but at the end of the day I
think a deal gets done